One of the approaches to
unify the production and
development environments
is called a golden image.
The idea is to take the operating
system, libraries, and
our application itself, and
wrap them up in a standard or
golden master image of a virtual
machine that can be used and
reused without the need to configure
each new machine individually.
These golden images can be used both
on desktop workstations as a virtual
machine and on servers.
You can also create golden
images of containers.
Another approach is to just install
a base operating system and then use
a configuration management system that
performs automatic installation and
configuration of software on
every machine under its control,
thus making sure that all the machines
have the same configuration.
To be sure of that, the installation
should start from the same base OS image
otherwise there could be
OS level differences.
The difference is that a golden image
system requires more work upfront, and
has to be regenerated whenever
there are any changes.
But once it's done, it is very fast to
boot up a new server or VM with it.
With the configuration management
system on the other hand,
booting up will be slower because every
machines needs to install the same
software on the first boot.
However, if there is a configuration
change, it's easy and fast to get these
changes out to the machines without
the need to regenerate the image.
And, of course,
you can have something in between.
For instance, install the base software
and libraries, perform the main
configuration, create a golden image and
then use it to bring up the machines.
Then once they're up,
use a configuration management system
to perform smaller rolling updates.
If both the image creation and
configuration management
processes are automated and
in a version control system,
it's easy to reproduce these steps.
And that's what you'll do as
the first step in this project.
Build a golden image that has all
the software necessary for dove and
also works in the cloud for
production server.
You won't work with a configuration
management system in this project
because that topic would require
a whole course of its own.
Maybe later.
For now, you'll have to download and
install a couple of programs.
Press next to see the instructions.